all right a disturbing development
tonight in a town in northern virginia
where we're now learning that fairfax
county schools was employing a middle
school counselor who was previously
convicted of a sex crime with a minor in
what governor glenn younkin says is a
complete and total failure to protect
students now this comes amid far left
lunacy in schools from coast to coast
including one teacher in utah who is now
on video talking about her classroom
built for quote non-white students take
a look
for the first time in my life i'm going
to be teaching at a majority white
school and i'm kind of interested to see
how
students and parents react to my
classroom or if they even notice
anything about it
um because it's built
for non-white students
and what i mean by that is like if you
look around and you interact with some
of the materials i have
you'll you'll notice that there's like
no white kids represented in that
clearly she wants her 15 minutes of fame
down in florida a father says that his
daughter attempted suicide not once but
twice
after her school encouraged others to
call her a boy and gave her a new name
while not notifying the parents the
father is now suing the clay county
school district and he will join us
along with his attorney tomorrow night
and amid all of these efforts by
teachers to indoctrinate your kids in
school and to turn their classrooms into
woke activism centers parents are
outraged and losing confidence in the
staffing abilities of the schools and
god forbid they go to a school board
meeting they'll be investigated for
domestic terrorism here with reaction
virginia governor glenn younkin governor
this played a big role in your state and
your election and now you see it's
expanding out all across the country
let's talk about what's going on in
fairfax and around the country and how
can parents stop this
well
first of all sean that this circumstance
in fairfax county is a colossal failure
on the local level from law enforcement
and from the school from the school
board and the superintendent to have
someone who in fact has been arrested
for soliciting sex from a minor
on staff for 20 months
and then to be arrested again and then
more time pass before they are finally
terminated from their position is beyond
belief and in fact when you couple that
with the experiences in northern
virginia from last year when i was a
candidate where we saw in loudoun county
a woman assaulted when the school board
in fact moved moved a student from one
school to another who had already been
accused and convicted of an assault this
is why parents are losing faith in
public schools this is why
last year all across virginia all across
virginia you saw parents matter signs
we are empowering parents in virginia
today we pass legislation to give them
the ability to make decisions with
regards to their children wearing a mask
or not to actually have visibility in
the classroom on the materials that are
being used
to make sure they're appropriate and
consistent with their values not the
teachers values but their values this is
about recognizing who has the strongest
role in educating children and it is
parents and then teachers
you know we have these very important
midterms coming up in around 80 days
obviously every candidate is going to
talk about record high inflation record
high gas prices open borders but i would
argue that you also showed the
importance in your race of talking about
what is happening in the school system
in the towns and cities they live in and
also simple things like law and order
safety and security for every citizen
be it in a town or a city and these
ought to be bread and butter issues that
republicans own and and run on in this
uh pro in this upcoming election would
you agree
yeah without a doubt and of course what
we saw last year was these kitchen table
issues have conservative solutions that
in fact voters not just republicans but
all voters support and education is at
the top of the list
yes inflation is running away from
america and that silent thief has been
let loose by washington and we see crime
literally causing disruption families
losing family members
day and night and we have got to invest
in back the blue and that's what we're
doing in virginia but at the top of the
list is education the future of our
country is the future of our children
and parents get it during the pandemic
they saw what was going on in the
classroom and this push to to drive
everything through the lens of race is
being rejected and this is not at the
expense of teaching all history the good
and the bad and recognizing that we
should embrace our diverse communities
but at the end of the day we've got to
stop teaching our children to judge
everything through the lens of race and
let's teach them critical math critical
history critical science the education
of our children is the topic that
republicans should win on we won on it
last year in virginia we see the same
parents matter signs in michigan and
nevada and new mexico we're going to win
these races based on making sure that
we're looking after our kids
reading writing math science history
computers and leave your woke agenda
home there are people that are called
parents let them instill the values they
believe in in their own children and
stay away from indoctrinating kids we
appreciate you being with us thank you
governor hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else